Ziya theater indicas using Gunther cos
your sensor proportions has done mankind
a genuine service heist your new book
has the title minded myself my century
the fact that you are receiving the 20th
century's last underwear literature
prize in this is confirmation of the
reason your cavalcade of the past
hundred years
you give ample proven you're an uncanny
ability to impersonate the voices of the
full hearing it is equally all those
bewitched by the hopes of politics and
technologies rendered these to provide
all great perspectives equaling core
core of thoughtlessness is enthusiasm I
read my yahoo negatives and critique
enthusiasm and a celebration of its
office listen my good memory and your
style with us all the greats and
repetitions and specifications and
stratification of different verses tells
us I know me the war we shall not be in
a hurry and so either when I pass demon
via the meat of a gang and you have
shown that as long as lit she remembers
he hastened to forget the steely that
poor animal mains a power so long as he
vac and an inert
was mentioned is about islands of
Ferguson he most advanced English I
would like to express our warm
congratulations as I now request you to
receive the Nobel Prize from the hands
of His Majesty the King